-Hi!
-Stunner. Stunner, as always.
Welcome back.
-Thank you. Thank you, guys.
-It is so great to see you.
-It's so good to be seen
and to see you.
-And to see you, as well.
And always looking gorgeous.
But look at you looking gorgeous
on the cover of
"Marie Claire" magazine
right there.
-Oh, my goodness!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ooh-la-la! Cover girl!
-It's a lot of work
went into that.
A lot of magician --
hair and makeup.
-No, I love this. Yeah.
-Yes.
-Well, you had --
Congratulations.
You had a big weekend.
-I did.
-You just got honored at the
American Black Film --
-Festival Honors. Yes.
-This is for --
-Thank you. That's very kind.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is big.
-Yeah.
-Excellence in the Arts Award.
-Yes.
-Can you explain?
Everyone was talking about
your red-carpet look.
And it's very --
[ Crowd cheering ]
I know -- stunning.
-Thank you.
So, this dress
was really special
because this is
an archival dress.
It was a dress worn by
Whitney Houston in 1996.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, I mean, how --
-Just crazy.
-But how do you even
think of that up?
Who thinks of that --
-So, her -- The designer,
Marc Bouwer,
had it in his archives.
And it had not been worn.
And in conversations,
my stylist,
my amazing stylist, Law --
he was talking to the designer.
And I was like, "Oh,
it's such an incredible dress.
It has to be the right moment."
And, so, if you're going to talk
about Black Excellence,
that's Whitney Houston.
So that was
the moment to honor her.
-Yeah, exactly.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-To honor her. Yes.
-What did it feel like
wearing it?
-I felt like a diva!
-Yeah.
-Yes!
-I have a picture of Whitney
performing in this dress here.
Look at that.
-I know, right?
Isn't that incredible?
-I mean, is that unbelievable?
You posted a very fun video
about wearing the dress
on your Instagram.
-I did.
-I just want to show everybody,
because I loved it.
-Oh, gosh.
-Let's take a look at this.
-What's cooler than wearing
Whitney Houston's dress?
-♪ Nothing ♪
♪ Nothing ♪
-Come on!
I love you! Come on!
That's the best.
"Nothing."
-You got to get the shake,
the Whitney shake.
-The shake, yeah.
Today is
International Women's Day.
-Happy
-And I'm so happy
you're on the show tonight.
-Thank you. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Do you know in like
more than 20 countries,
it's an actual national holiday,
a public holiday,
where people get the day off?
-Ooh! Let's --
-I've been whispering that to
all the women on your staff.
-Yeah. Everyone
is walking out now.
-Everyone in that picture.
-Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
Everybody has the day off.
"No, please come back. Please.
I need you, I need you,
I need you."
-They'll be back tomorrow.
-Yeah.
You were telling me backstage
that you're working on
your memoir.
-Yes.
-And I want to talk to you
about that, because --
-Okay.
-What's it like?
And how far are you?
And how did you get the
inspiration to --
-I guess when "Scandal"
was ending, it was really
kind of a turning point
in my life.
It was sort of the end
of an era.
And I spent some time
learning more about myself,
and it just made me
want to share
some of what I was learning.
But I don't -- I mean,
I'm at the point
where I'm in final edits.
But it's true,
that thing they say,
that you're never
really done writing.
They just take it away
from you at some point.
Like, I'm at the deadline,
so I have to hand it over.
But I'm just, like,
so obsessed with every word
and wanting to make sure that
every single feeling and word
and sentiment and comma and
period is in the right place.
-It's called
"Thicker Than Water"
is the title.
-Yes.
-What's the background?
-It's a lot about family, and --
-It is?
-Yeah.
And what family means to me.
And -- Yeah.
-And do you have your family,
then your career,
because, I mean,
I know a little bit about you,
but I want to know more.
-Well, you'll get it.
You'll have to buy the book.
-Yeah. Alright, I will, I will.
-No spoilers.
-I will totally do it.
-No spoilers!
-Yeah, no spoilers here, no.
-But family is
really important to me.
I mean, even with this show,
"Unprisoned," like,
I'm really -- I think
I'm very interested in how
we find family and create family
and what family means to us.
And so that's a lot of
what my work is
centering around these days.
-I like "Unprisoned"
because it's a drama --
it's a family drama,
but it's funny.
-It's a dramedy for sure.
-Yes, it's a dramedy.
-Yes, yes, yes.
-That's a good word for it.
-And, I mean, I mostly do a lot
of drama, but you know, like,
the best week of my life,
outside of my honeymoon,
was my week on "SNL."
-You were fantastic.
-Like, I love doing comedy.
-You're great at being funny.
-Thank you, coming from you.
So, I really love this show,
because it's about kind of
meaningful, heartfelt moments,
but it's very, very funny,
as well.
-Can you set up
what the show is about?
-Sure. I better be able to.
-Yeah.
-So, it's about a dad.
The dad is really
the center of the show.
It's about a dad and a daughter
and a grandson.
Now, obviously, I'm neither
a father nor a grandson,
so I'm the daughter.
-Yes, of course.
-And my dad has been in and out
of prison my whole life.
And the show really is about
what happens
when he is released from prison.
So it's about the experience of
what it's like to be
a formerly incarcerated person
and also what it's like
to love
a formerly incarcerated person
who's re-entering society.
And, you know,
there are 80 million Americans
living with criminal records.
So this show is
really about so many of us,
because either we have
a criminal record
or many of us love somebody who
has a criminal record,
and that impacts our lives
in very deep ways.
But, also, really,
there are very funny moments.
-Yeah. And how do you
come back into society?
And how do you deal with family
and all that stuff?
And Delroy Lindo.
-Delroy Lindo is brilliant.
-Yeah, we love him.
-He plays the dad on the show.
He's so spectacular. I love him.
-Was he your first choice?
-He was my only choice.
-Oh, really?
When I read the script
and came on as a producer
and started developing it,
I was like,
"There is one guy
that I see in this role."
He didn't know,
but he was the one.
-Yeah.
-And, so,
then I did a Zoom with him.
This was back
when we were only Zooming.
And I talked to him and kind of
convinced him that
what we were doing
was going to be important.
I had seen him in "Da 5 Bloods"
and had --
have been obsessed with him
for a long time.
So I called Spike Lee
to get his number.
And then I called him,
and then he said, "Yes."
And I was like,
"We have a show!"
-Yes! We have a show!
And I want to show a clip.
Here is Kerry Washington
in "Unprisoned."
-Yes.
-Take a look.
-Ready?
-Yeah.
Ow! Oh, hallelujah!
Whoo!
-Once a week, check-ins for drug
testing and career counseling.
And I assume
he'll be living with you.
-Oh, no. That's a no go.
-Oh, no, absolutely not.
-Well, we do recommend
parolees live with family
to give them the best chance
of staying out.
-Yeah. No, of course.
That makes sense.
But I-I only have two rules,
and one of them is that
he cannot live me.
The other is,
don't ask me for money.
-And don't ask for money.
But what my daughter
doesn't know is that
I'm out for good this time.
And you -- you're going to see,
for your last --
-I have heard this before --
in 1986, 1992, 1998 --
actually, December of '97,
and then most famously in 2005.
-Yeah. Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Kerry Washington, everybody.
Stream all episodes
of "Unprisoned"
this Friday on Hulu.